this is modern-day reindeer herding
Sweden's indigenous Sami people crossing
frozen lakes on snowmobiles to feed the
reindeer by hand a symptom of their
disappearing postures here in the Arctic
reindeer herding is so important for the
Sami culture in in Sweden we are
struggling to just getting the reindeer
to survive every winter and it's very
costly and put a lot of strains and
families and reindeer herders the
effects of climate change and the impact
of mining and dams are part of a growing
list of problems adding to that strain
these reindeer have been moved up into
the mountains for the spring and summer
where despite all the dangers that face
them they should at least be safe from a
new one that emerged over the winter
that new danger was a spate of killings
of reindeer suspected to have been
carried out by Swedish neighbors in
retaliation for a court case that a Sami
community one against the government and
which gave them back the right to decide
who hunts and fishes on their land
lash Ola Yannick is one of those who has
found his animals slaughtered in the
woods I lit my reindeer loose here and a
man drove up and said you don't come
here with your reindeer or will shoot
them we've already shot seven or eight
and if I meet you alone in the forest
I'll shoot you too it's been a tense
winter most of us Swedes are good people
but we have this clique that has such
hatred towards reindeer and reindeer
herders tensions rose in January after
Sweden's Supreme Court ruled in favor of
the Sami reindeer herding union of
Guinea's whose land stretches some 300
kilometres from here near the Norwegian
border it could set a precedent for 50
other such areas covering half of Sweden
and may also hinder plans for more wind
and water power plants and mines which
have already decimated reindeer pastures
the government in Stockholm has
condemned what it described as racism
threats and hate against the Sami but
hasn't commented on any strengthening of
their rights we've got some evidence
the Supreme Court stated that the
international indigenous rights
conventions Sweden is bound by must be
observed in decisions effect in the Sami
we must see changes in legislation and
see it applied not least when it comes
to mining and forestry back up north the
case has caused uncertainty both for
Swedish hunters who now need permissions
from the reindeer herders Union and for
Sami who don't have membership tempering
enthusiasm for what is a rare victory
for their people
and while the coronavirus devastates the
economy the creation of yet more
industry on these lands could be a
bigger priority than giving the Sami a
real say in the destiny of the country
Paul Reis al Jazeera vice alotta Sweden